-Thanks to newly-developed
technology,
we here at "Late Night"
now have the ability
to re-cord -- to record...
Re-cord.
[ Laughter ]
To re-cord --
the act of recording.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
...the tiny voice -- Please.
No, I don't...
Don't treat me like
a sweetheart candy.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ] And finally --
Anyway, it records
the tiny voice
that is inside
Donald Trump's head.
And you might be surprised
to know that,
like everyone's inner voice,
Donald Trump's is filled with
paralyzing fear and self doubt,
so here is, once again,
the tiny voice in the back
of Donald Trump's head.
♪♪♪♪
-Perhaps you could tell them...
-Hey, Donald, it's the tiny
voice in the back of your head,
and I know today is about
border security,
but don't you think
you should say something
about Ted Cruz's beard?
Ted Cruz's beard is a threat
to all Americans.
It is such a bad beard.
It looks as though
he put glue on his face
and rolled around
on a barbershop floor.
[ Laughter ]
It looks like Wolverine
if he didn't have any powers,
although you probably
shouldn't talk.
Your windbreaker's so open,
it looks like you're
wearing a lobster bib.
This is not a good-looking
group of people.
♪♪♪♪